[Musique]
salut je commence cette vidéo par la fin
là on est le dimanche 7 janvier il est
17h à new york
je commence par la fin parce que je vais
vous expliquer j'ai un problème avec ça
qui m'a quand même planté une partie de
la vidéo avec des bruits très très
bizarre donc bon désolé d'introduire là
dessus c'est juste pour vous compreniez
et que vous m'excusez parce que le
premier plan que j'ai fait ce matin et
je vais pas leur faire donc forcément il
ya du bruit dessus donc je vais m'en
excuser désolé introduira dessus et on
va tout de suite parlé de cassis
[Musique]
new york tout juste 7 heures du mat
on va parler du roi des blogueurs
aujourd'hui je vais parler de celui qui
m'a donné envie
et comme beaucoup de monde d'ailleurs de
faire des vidéos sur youtube cuisine et
statte son studio est à peine deux
kilomètres d'ici on va avoir énormément
de choses sur lui aujourd'hui on va
reprendre plein de choses mais avant
toute chose ce qu'on va faire on va
faire comme lui
run matinale à 7h du mat sauf que là il
fit -15° son énorme vague de froid sur
new york
mais bon on s'en fout quand on aime on
compare d'ailleurs et c'est parti
[Musique]
m
g
[Musique]
et
c'est quelque chose qu'on leur colle
surtout quand un peu sportif à moins 15
comment il fait qu'ici
c'est trop grevant le sport je ne veux
pas une kate 18h du gras ça ira mieux
chabot qu'ici chip cox
[Musique]
les yeux
verdict dhabi c'est très très bon il
perdure à finir j'ai pas réussi par
contre c'est pas cadeau cadeaux compris
si vous voulez si vous allez à new york
je conseille quand même de venir vous
trouverez bise au croisement de hudson
street et de moore
c'est très très bon vous allez voir y
aller maintenant
[Musique]
oh
radio simba et les stats d'un side
m
la bnm de la prière
il est à new york
non
[Musique]
allez moi nous
à
vous avez toute petite voiture de police
elle a quelques années de ça de se
moquer sur une des ses dernières filles
ou d'ailleurs et c'est pas mal cher
point là dessus l'idée est donc là on
est à l'angle de broadway et de franklin
street et juste devant moi vous avez les
bureaux de cuisine et stats au premier
étage juste à côté bîmes en héritage là
c'est les bureaux de cuisine et de stats
avec je me suis voyez bien ces caméras
clair tout le temps filmé en permanence
et juste à côté
ici vous avez bible qui est la boîte que
kevin est apte à fonder cofondé et a
rendu à cnn ya quelques années l'année
dernière des recettes en 2002 un an et
demi en 2016 pour 25 millions de dollars
je crois que c'était justement
complètement dingue qui fait du super
contenu de qualité d'ailleurs je vous
invite à vous abonner parce que c'est
vraiment un truc génial vous emilien
dans la description qu'il ne connaissait
pas parce que franchement c'est tout cas
connaissent et james génial quasi office
bîmes sans lieu de pèlerinage ici
bon
[Musique]
et
mais ici c'est les lurons du casino de
stats nos selphy mais on dit pour ne pas
filmer ou pas donc je filme c'est là où
sont ses bureaux ça c'est l'endroit où
quasi achète ses valises pour partir
[Musique]
oh
point de détail on est juste à côté de
son bureau c'est quand même intéressant
savoir
[Musique]
un jeu
là on est au 35 great jones street
c'est l'endroit où se trouvent les
bureaux de billy billy c'est la marque
de la femme de cases in stat candice
poule nedstat s'est jusqu'ici dans cet
immeuble là si vous jetez on va aller
jusqu'au bout et d'ailleurs si vous
connaissez si vous suivez les vidéos de
questionnaires ça que vous verrez que
les choses qu'on reconnaît notamment le
parking derrière qu'on a déjà vu
plusieurs fois dans différentes vidéos
lily c'est une marque qui fait des
bijoux fabrique des bijoux il ya des
t-shirts partenaires ne manquez ginestas
des t-shirts ville et il a déjà dit dans
plusieurs vidéos qui était très fier de
ce que faisait qu'en dise qu'elle était
elle aussi partie 0 créer sa propre
marque qui en tout cas a l'air de
marcher donc félicitations c'est
vraiment sympa donc c'est juste ici 35
great jones street est désolé pour mon
accent
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
alors au final pourquoi est ce que tout
le monde aime autant kessy pourquoi
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment adoré qui a plus de 8 millions
500 mille abonnés et ça continue de
monter pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya autant
de succès parce que c'est un mec simple
c'est un mec qui vient de nulle part
qu'il était parti très jeune de chez sa
mère il eu son premier enfant il avait
même pas 20 ans il est venu à new york
rejoint de son frère pour tenter sa
chance et ça lui a plutôt bien réussi il
a fait des vidéos qui ont pesé il a eu
sa série avec son frangin / edge bio
ensuite sur youtube avec son blog il a
carrément cartonné et maintenant il
s'imposait comme le roi développeurs le
number one
celui qui a ouvert une voie et qui a
vraiment créé un style donc on retrouve
effectivement un peu partout qu'ils y
c'est quelqu'un qui cartonne d'ailleurs
ce petit produit ainsi vous allez à new
york 12 presse moi j'ai pris le 12
presse anti âge avec du concombre et je
sais pas quoi dedans c'est vegan c'est
pas mauvais j'ai l'impression de boire
du concombre et de la flotte mais bon
c'est pas mal enfin bon pour 10 $ ça
fait quand même un peu cher c'est quand
même pas mal
et sinon ce petit produit donc je vais
essayer la le la sauce species in stat
qui est quand même quand brossé sort de
guy de ramener un petit souvenir
donc voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur casino stats
merci d'abord regarder cette vidéo je
voudrais bien sûr amener ces des jolies
pousse à vous abonner et je vous dis à
très bientôt
soyez sages portez vous bien
[Musique]
mario